there's a sex of the city sequel series
called and just like that
and of course
the show is absurdly over the top woke
which is to be expected
i never watched the original sex in the
city but i i imagine that the original
for its time was also pretty woke
so there should be no surprise here but
there's one scene in particular that's
made its rounds online and uh it's
it's if you didn't know any better and
you didn't know anything about sex in
the city or anything else and you saw
this you would think that it was you
would almost think it was a parody you
would almost think it was like a babylon
b skit making fun of wokeness but it's
not i assure you so let's watch this
sorry he just told me someone's quick
with the pronouns uh it's fine
i am the professor
you're the professor yeah you're naya
wallace
yes why do you seem so surprised well
you're braids
a law professor can't have hair like
mine why is that oh no no i didn't i
didn't mean
because of the braids i was i was i was
just thrown because
the braids are are so different than the
hair in your photo on the columbia
website my comment had nothing
whatsoever to do with it being a black
hairstyle i knew that you were black
when i signed up for this class that was
important to me
you signed up for this class because i'm
black
well not just because you're black i
picked this class because
you're such a force in academia on top
of everything you do as a community
activist god i sound like such a brown
nose
i mean um
please just forget that i ever said
anything about your hair
hair has
nothing whatsoever to do with er
appropriateness or intelligence or
gravitas obviously i mean do i look like
someone who attaches any significance to
hair i let mine go gray and i don't care
if it makes me look old not that i'm
ageist do i sound ageist
you really want me to answer that
question
uh again
as far as i can tell again i've never i
haven't seen the show now i would rather
shoot myself than watch this but as far
as i can tell this is this is not
supposed to be a satire or parody
or making fun of wokeness
so that's what you get there this is
real this is like one of those race
hoaxes
just like the one we talked about
yesterday of the of the doctor who
claimed that someone stopped a black
doctor in a suit and tie full suit and
tie at a hospital with a name tag that
says doctor on it claiming that someone
stopped him in the hallway and said
excuse me uh i assume that you're a
member of the custodial staff
please go go clean my toilets at once
that's what he claimed and um
i'll be clear very clearly a race hoax
from dr smilet this is one of those race
hoaxes acted out
this is because this is the kind of
conversation the kind of interaction
that especially elitists on the left um
they think that these sorts of things
happen out in the world
and that's why they're they're incapable
of coming up with a race hoax that's
believable
jesse smellette a hollywood guy he's
very privileged very you know wealthy
somehow has managed to be wealthy and uh
and famous as an actor
he doesn't spend a lot of time around
normal people
now jesse smellet from his prison cell
if he's watching that
he's probably thinking himself well yeah
that's how this happens all the time
that a white person
would say to a black person well i
assume that you're not a professor
because of your hair
what i've because i've never seen a
professor with braids what
so this is uh
this you know the people that that write
this they all exist in that that same
bubble
and that's what makes it so
unintentionally hilarious because this
would this just this is not life this is
not what happens
but for anyone who was disappointed or
upset as some people on social media
appear to be
that the new sex in the city is woke
i've seen a lot of complaints from
people so this new sex of the city
sequel is terrible
this is a this is a disappointment there
they are ruining the legacy of sex in
the city
what did you think was going gonna
happen
just know this now
okay
this is
every franchise
every tv series
every film
it's it's all this now if there's any if
there's any franchise or series or movie
that came out prior to you know seven or
eight years ago
that you liked
you should not want there to be any kind
of sequel or remake or anything
i saw on twitter someone someone put out
a kind of a question
for everybody and the question was
something like um
[Music]
you know what
which which series have been the most
ruined um by by going woke and the
answer of course is all of them
this is what they all are
hollywood is not capable of producing
anything but this now
and so you have to understand it's it's
also
now that's a tv series so not eligible
for an academy award but
the academy has made this a rule now for
it's basically required now if you're
making a film and you want to
have a chance at winning an academy
award
which i'm not even sure why you'd care
about that anymore because the none of
the movie going public doesn't care
about it
that used to be one of the great one of
the values of winning an academy award
is that is that the public cares about
it and so if you can say that i'm an
academy award-winning actor more more
people are likely to go watch your next
movie that's not the case anymore nobody
cares but
the academy has put rules down saying
you have to have x number of trans
people an x number of this and that so
this is every single series every movie
it will all be this
amazon has that new uh
lord of the rings prequel trilogy come
on they spent like a billion dollars on
it
a lot of people including many of
conservatives i follow on social media
very excited about it
because they're big lord of the rings
fans
well don't you one this is
amazon
okay what do you think they're gonna do
to it
and then you're gonna sit down you're
gonna watch it and be disappointed
because there's a there's a trans
non-binary disabled hobbit or something
of course
that's all of them
if it's coming from hollywood it is all
this they cannot do anything but this
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated